All right, we're going to go ahead and get started. Good afternoon.
I hope you've all been enjoying this extraordinary annual meeting.
I am Dr. William Pao, currently CEO of Revelio Therapeutics,
and it is my great pleasure to introduce this year's AACR
Margaret Foti Award for Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements in
Cancer Research.
The AACR established this award in 2007 in
honor of Chief Executive Officer, Dr.
Margaret Foti, for her exemplary leadership of the AACR,
and for her sustained and extraordinary dedication to the conquest of
cancer through fostering research, scholarly publications,
communication, science education and training, and public education
over many years.
This award recognizes true champions of cancer research,
people who share the sustained commitment of Dr.
Foti to the prevention and cure of all cancers, and whose
leadership and extraordinary achievements in cancer research have made a major
impact in the field.
Our honoree for the 2026 AACR Margaret Foti Award for
Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements in Cancer Research is Dr.
Anthony Ribas of the University of California, Los Angeles.
You have to bear with me because you have so many accomplishments that it will take
a long introduction here. Dr. Ribas is an internationally recognized
physician-scientist, whose work has transformed the treatment of melanoma
and advanced the broader field of cancer immunotherapy.
His career is defined by an extraordinary commitment to integrating basic
science, clinical research, and patient care to develop more
effective cancer treatments. Dr.
Ribas' research has focused on understanding melanoma biology and its
interaction with the immune system to improve therapeutic outcomes for patients.
He has been instrumental in the clinical development of multiple FDA-approved
therapies, including a first-in-class anti-PD-1 immune
checkpoint inhibitor, pembrolizumab, as well as the anti-CTLA4
agent, tremelimumab. These agents have helped
redefine the standard of care for melanoma and many other
malignancies. He's also played a key role in developing targeted
combination therapies, including BRAF and MEK inhibitors,
such as vemurafenib with cobimetinib, and dabrafenib with
trametinib, significantly improving outcomes for patients with BRAF mutant
tumors.
Beyond drug development, Dr. Ribas has led pioneering studies to uncover the
mechanisms of response and resistance to immunotherapy.
His work has provided critical insights that guide the rational design of
next-generation combination therapies aimed at overcoming treatment
resistance and extending the benefits of immunotherapy to more patients.
Dr. Ribas and his team have advanced innovative cell-based therapies, including
investigator-initiated clinical trials using genetically engineered
T cells and hematopoietic stem cells.
Notably, he led a first-of-its-kind clinical trial combining modified
mature T cells with engineered blood-forming stem cells to generate both
immediate and long-term antitumor responses.
His research also integrates cutting-edge technologies, including
nanotechnology and molecular imaging approaches, such as PET-based
monitoring, to better understand immune responses and guide therapeutic
decision-making. He continues to lead efforts in developing novel CAR
T-cell therapies targeting solid tumors, including those expressing
IL13Rα2.
In addition to his scientific contributions, Dr.
Ribas is a recognized leader in the cancer research community.
He serves as Director of the Tumor Immunology Program at the Jonsson Comprehensive
Cancer Center and Director of the Parker Institute for Cancer Immunotherapy Center
at UCLA. He also previously served as Chair of the Melanoma
Committee for the Southwest Oncology Group and as President of
AACR.
Dr. Ribas has authored highly cited publications that have shaped the field
with an extensive body of work that continues to influence both research and
clinical practice. His many honors include the AACR Richard and
Hinda Rosenthal Award, the AACR-CRI Lloyd
J. Old Award in Cancer Immunology, the William B.
Coley Award, and the European Society for Medical Oncology Award for
Translational Research. He's also an elected member of the National Academy of
Medicine and other prestigious societies.
So needless to say, the impact of Dr. Ribas' work has been profound.
His leadership in the development of immunotherapies, particularly pembrolizumab,
has driven a paradigm shift in the treatment of melanoma and other cancers,
improving and extending the lives of countless patients worldwide.
So it is my great honor to introduce my colleague and
friend, the 2026 recipient of the AACR Margaret Foti Award
for Leadership and Extraordinary Achievements in Cancer Research, Dr.
Anthony Ribas.
Unless
you
want-
Oh, you want to? Okay, sorry. I guess we take a vote.
Thank you very much, William, for this very kind introduction.
I'm glad that they gave you five minutes to do it.
You went back on all of my career, so that's very kind.
I want to thank AACR and the nominating committee, and
Dr. William Pao as chair of the committee for this great honor.
To have this in your CV, I've been
going through the halls, some people I don't know,
stop me and congratulate on having this prestigious award.
So, having an award named on
Margaret Foti, it's really something that I
really appreciate.
I'm going to talk about several things, but here are my disclosures.
Please take these into account.
Some of them are companies that unfortunately no longer exist.
I was the completely 100% virtual president.
I became president at the time where we're all shut down.
We did this passing of the
baton or whatever it was, and it was
right afterI had been
nominated to become to serve as president, and also was the chair of the
organizing committee of the 2020 annual meeting, and that got
canceled, terminated, denied, closed, axed, everything
possible. But within a month, we
decided that
the people who come to ACR send their
best work here, and that's something that we needed to share with
everybody despite having a pandemic.
So we organized the first of two virtual
annual meetings with platforms that existed but we were not using,
and the first one had 61,000 registrants.
I ran 10,000 people at
audience sessions from
my balcony on a cotton T-shirt and without a haircut.
But then we learned how to do this for the second annual meeting,
and now we have 40,000 people more showed up, making up
the largest medical conference and event ever organized.
We made it all free of charge, so we had
a lot of people joining in, even non-people joining in.
And you can see that we learned how to use these multiple squares, things
that now everybody uses on many conferences.
At the same time, there was this civil unrest.
There were things that had happened that were pushing how
we think about our society and how some of our
colleagues and patients are being perceived
before they have any chance at things.
So we thought we had to talk about this, and we put
up,
how
would you call it? A statement about it, and then during the annual meeting, we
organized panels. I learned so much from so many colleagues that
have become very good friends about why do we do all
of this work, and how do we have to make sure that everybody
has the same opportunities, and every
patient can get access to the benefits of things.
And all of this, I thank the ACR. I thank for
being put in this position to be able to
share this leadership and work with Marge Horie and all of the organization.
So now I'll go to the scientific part of this.
I assume that the
award is in part also for having been
part of one of the things that-- A story
that is a beautiful story about how science
has changed the treatment of patients and how we have been
able to understand the science of the cancer and how it interacts with the immune
system. And it starts
close to 25 years ago, when Michael Stratton,
Richard Marais, and others, Neil Rosen and
Daniel Peiper and others, had been studying this pathway,
the MAP kinase pathway, and noted that there
was a mutation that drives half of melanomas.
When you have that mutation on, it turns on this
signaling that phosphorylates ERK and tells the cells to be growing all
the time. And the idea was, if you block this, and Plexxikon made a
drug that blocks it, then you can have this night and day difference where
the cells that were all on now turn off.
When you make a targeted drug like this and you bring it to patients that
have these mutations, we started to see responses like these
ones, where within days and weeks,
large metastatic melanomas
responded. It was a very reproducible finding.
Here's the Phase I trial and the waterfall plot
with Keith Flaherty as the first author.
You can see that the majority of patients had responses.
Going down is a waterfall, is responses.
This was followed with the Phase II trial, and that's the regular drug development,
and I'll make a point about this. The Phase II trial, what did we learn compared
to the Phase I? Nothing. We just put more patients.
More patients got responses. Very few had resistance disease.
Unfortunately, at that time, there was only one way to approval, which was to
do a Phase III trial. And the Phase III trial, the patients who
received what became vemurafenib, it looks exactly the same as the
Phase I trial. The waterfall plot doesn't tell us anything
else. We have responses in these tumors.
The problem is that there was a control group that received chemotherapy, and
the clinical trial had to be stopped
a month after the last patient was enrolled because
the first interim analysis showed such a big difference that it was
unethical to continue that clinical trial.
When some change like this happens with a disease that we had
basically nothing that worked and now we have all these patients responding,
the lay press starts being interested.
And here I'm going back also many years on a series of
articles in the front page of "The New York Times." The first
couple were a focus on Keith Flaherty as the
lead investigator of this program, but there
were several others involved. And by the fourth article,
the journalist had started visit several places and
came to UCLA and learned about my colleague Bartosz Chmielowski
treating two cousins. One of them, who had BRAF mutant
metastatic melanoma that came at the time of the Phase II trial,
received the Plexxikon drug at that time, responded, and did well
for quite a long period of time. Then his other cousin came at
the time when it was the Phase III trial and got randomized to the control arm
and died within a month.This clinical
trial has changed drug development, and this
article, these two cousins, because at that time,
people were interviewed, including Rick Pastor, and said, "Well, when you have a
targeted drug that works in such precise way and gives such
responses from the start, you don't need a phase three clinical trial.
That should be made available to patients before that."
By the fifth article, we're already shifting a little bit.
Well, it was really good initially, but the
majority, not all patients, there's around a
third of the patients who respond never relapse, and I've been following some
patients for over 20 years now.
But by the fifth one, we already knew that many
of the patients who responded progressed.
And by the time the first snows were falling in Central
Park, here's my colleague Roger Lo in the front page of "The New York
Times," making a biopsy of a patient who had responded and progressed.
And
with Roger, we're studying what is the mechanism of this, and
Roger elucidated that whenever you block BRAF,
that there can be an alternate pathway through receptor tyrosine
kinases or mutations or amplifications of
BRAF that reactivate the same MAP kinase pathway, which
led to the next
question, which is, what if we block BRAF and MEK?
There have been MEK inhibitors
generated by several people.
Judy Straus Leopold at Pfizer had generated one, and I just met her this
morning with Neil Rosen at breakfast.
And when we tested this, I said, well, if we put, here
was the vemurafenib that was so good initially, so much better than
chemotherapy. If we now block BRAF and MEK, we had this
very significant improvement, and that led to three generations of these
BRAF and MEK inhibitors being approved.
Meanwhile, we were developing cellular immunotherapies.
I had gone to UCLA. I moved from Barcelona, Spain, in
1996 to do a one or two-year postdoc
in the laboratory of Jim Economou, who was a surgeon who was doing
gene therapy and immunotherapy in models of
melanoma and liver cancer. And
by the time we did some research, I was so excited
about understanding more how the immune system worked, and I stuck
with one of the two cancers, melanoma, which in
retrospect was a good choice. And I was reading papers
from many, including papers from
Jim Allison on the regulation of the immune
system, how co-stimulation works, something that still
escapes me a little bit, and how he figured out that there was co-inhibitory
molecules that could be blocked, and then you could have an immune response to
cancer. So we started working with CTLA-4 blocking
antibodies on treating patients.
I'll go back to a more lay press. In October
2007, there's this
Forbes,
Forbes was very big at that time, and they had this article that said,
"Magic Bullet for Melanoma."
They had another article that
questioned the recession of 2008.
So these people in 2007 already knew that 2008, there
was going to be a recession.
I should have read that article. It would have been economically better, but
I didn't. I stuck with the melanoma one.
And the melanoma one was written by Bob Langreth, and I don't know if Bob
is in the audience, but Bob received one of the
ACR
Journalist Awards yesterday. And Bob had been following some
of the patients on early clinical trials on CTLA-4 blocking antibodies
that Jed Wolchok,
Steve Hodi, and myself and others were treating.
And this is one of my patients, a
physician from New Zealand who had the same age as me, who had
two daughters, one one year older and one one year younger than mine,
and who had metastatic melanoma with liver, adrenal, bone
metastasis progressing on chemotherapy, on IL-2, on
everything, on a vaccine, and he was told, "You have months to live and
just get your things in order." And he started coming to
receive the CTLA-4 blocking antibody, and here, some years later
with Ed, I went to Auckland for a meeting, and
we decided to go up and hike a volcano
in the Bay of Auckland. Ed continues to have a normal life
since then. So this is the impact of these immunotherapies.
But there was something that was not right because
the CTLA-4 checkpoint is at the activation step of the
immune system, and there's later checkpoints, in particular PD-1.
And it turns out that there's more T-cells in humans are
stuck in the PD-1 checkpoint than in the CTLA-4 checkpoint.
Because if you block the PD-1 checkpoint, there's more responses and
by all practical means that we know.
But this is in the minority of cancers that there's
all these T-cells
previously activated.
And the key thing is,
is the cancer immunogenic?
Are there preexisting T-cells that recognize alterations in
the cancer that allow to differentiate normal cells from cancer
cells and attack cancer cells? It's very logical, but I go to meetings
like this, and I think the concept escapes many
discussions because they start talking about, I don't know, whole
bunch of tumor microenvironment cells that may modulate
or turn on or off the immune system or I don't know what.
It is the T-cells that have the right T-cell receptor that
recognize-a cancer differentially.
And when this happens, you can have responses like this one.
This is a CAT scans of a patient at baseline with this large mass
in the lung, pleural effusion. There was more melanoma in the liver than there
was normal
liver. And here we have a response, and if also you go to meetings and they
say patients with liver metastasis don't respond, please,
that's not the case. It has to be
some other biology. It's not only the location.
This patient had progressed on everything.
But I'm not only showing this, and I'm not going to be showing you much of the
data.
I'm showing this because there's a personal thing about treating these patients.
This is
the actual patient,
Tom. He sent me an email said, "Hi, Toni.
Yes, you have permission to use the pictures in your slideshow."
Because I obviously asked could I use these.
And you can see that he has muscle wasting.
The melanoma is eating up from his body.
He fell and bumped his head, and the clinical trial didn't
require to make an MRI, so I refused to do an MRI.
We'll just treat you because he would have been excluded if there was brain
metastasis. I don't know they were ever there, but they're very
suspicious.
So here we have Tom some time later doing a pamphlet of
UCLA promoting things, and he continues to respond.
And then here's Tom giving a lecture.
So I'm showing in my lecture a picture of Tom showing
a picture of both of us somewhere. So it's like a Velázquez
painting. You try to start thinking how many mirrors are there
or views.
This is the current status of this field.
This is how many
immune checkpoint blockade agents have been approved and which
approvals.
There's,
I think at least 60 indications and 11 of these immune
checkpoint blocking therapies approved.
There's notable patients like President Carter who had
metastatic melanoma to the liver and the brain, got them both treated, and then
received a little bit of anti-PD-1 and died from old
age.
And the key thing was to understand why does this happen?
And I said my
thoughts about it, but it's based on studying multiple biopsies from
multiple patients in early studies of PD-1 blocking
antibodies,
where there had to be that this is when
you could publish a paper in Nature with just
immunohistochemistry, and this is CD8 immunohistochemistry.
At baseline, we see all these dots outside the tumor.
After therapy, one of these
multiple metastases that we biopsied, T-cells infiltrate.
They infiltrate with different speeds.
Larger lesions respond
later. And then here there's biopsies from 24 patients,
and you can barely quantify CD8 T-cells at baseline and
afterwards. And it's because this is a targeted
immunotherapy.
It only works if there's the target and the receptor, the PD-1
receptor colocalized with the PD-L1 in any part of the
biopsy. It doesn't have to be all of it.
It just tells you indirectly that there's some T-cells that have the right T-cell
receptor to recognize the cancer and make interferon, and
that's how the cancer then protects itself from PD-L1.
If this interaction is not there, these therapies will not be working.
So
we want to then try to understand this and try to select patients
better and treat patients better.
And there's this
subset of melanomas, a separate cancer called desmoplastic melanoma
that also changes many of the paradigms that you can hear in many
conferences, including this one, which is that fibrosis is
bad for immunotherapy or for cancer therapy.
Desmoplasia is the
pathologist term for fibrosis, and so these are fibrotic
tissue. It's a fibrotic cancer. All of the blue
is the strands of collagen that make up the cancer.
There's only isolated cancer cells in
between. And it's dedifferentiated. It's not even pigmented.
It's hard to diagnose. So this dedifferentiated
melanoma that's highly fibrosed, will it respond to therapy?
Well, it has a high tumor mutational burden because
it's induced by ultraviolet
light exposure. So with my colleagues at SWOG, we thought that
we should test prospectively if patients with this subtype
of melanoma would respond. So we did a study
S1512 that had a neoadjuvant cohort with three doses of
anti-PD-1 before surgery and
metastatic advanced disease, where they got up to two years
of therapy. And here we have the
results in the neoadjuvant, 71. We had
biopsies at baseline and then resections around three months
later. And 71% of the
post-therapy resections, the pathologists couldn't find a single
cancer cell. They were all gone within just three doses of
anti-PD-1. And in metastatic disease, there's an 89% response
rate, telling us that there is this consistent
finding in certain cancers. MSI high colorectal
cancer would be the other where you can have these results, and
these are real cancers. And each one of these is a fibros
tumor. You see this PET scan at baseline and this major response.
And we entered 55 patients to this clinical trial between both
arms. And at three years, there's only been one patient known to
die from metastatic or from advanced desmoplastic melanoma,
telling us that from time to time, we get the science really right and give the
right treatments to the right patients.And
all of this works because there's these rare
T-cells that have a T-cell receptor that recognize the
cancer differentially.
And once this happens, they're
turned off by PD-1, and if we block this, then the T-cells
start making interferon gamma, which makes the target cancer cell, the one that
they're physically attached, a better target because
now it starts making
1,500 interferon-stimulated genes within 24
hours. And these interferon-stimulated genes change the
target, so now the cancer cells are better recognized by the
immune system. And they start making chemokines, so now the cancer cells
make proteins that attract more immune cells into the
tumor, and those chemokines attract more tumor-specific
antigen cells and more other immune cells, and they keep making more
interferon gamma. And actually, it can go up to 40
cell layers in studies done by Tom Schumacher with an
interferon gamma reporter
construct. Which tells us that this
recognition of a cancer cell as abnormal
changes the tumor microenvironment, which was unfriendly for
T-cells. You can barely culture any T-cells
in the pH and in the
microenvironment of a tumor. And now by making interferon gamma respond
genes, the cancer cells are helping the immune response.
I mean, the only way to know this would be if we do a
genetic experiment where if I'm saying that it's an interferon gamma,
you could knock out the interferon gamma receptor and then
see if this reverses. And I'm not going to show
you the data, but it turns out that
melanoma has done it because, in some cases, with acquired
resistance, where the patients responded and
progressed,
we can see the
resistant cancers have homozygous
JAK1 or JAK2
loss-of-function mutations, which are the kinase that are
required for interferon gamma signaling or have loss of
MHC expression by loss of beta-2 microglobulin.
So
what do we do with all this knowledge?
Well, we can change how we deliver these therapies.
The standard of care for stage III melanomas and lung
cancers or other cancers that can respond to these therapies was to do
surgery. And when you do surgery,
you take the tumor, and the tumor has all these immune cells there, and
those are thrown away. And then we try to stimulate the immune response by
giving the immune checkpoint blockade therapies.
So with my colleagues at SWOG and following work by Christian
Blanck and the NKI and Georgina Long and ideas from
John Hannon and Tom Schumacher, we thought that, what if we gave
the therapy before the surgery?
Stimulate the immune response before the
tumor's taken out, and the T-cells from the tumor can now
start expanding, and then they can do the surgery, and
then we should have a better outcome.
And when we proposed this study with Sapna Patel and
Megan Northuis, we were told several times that this was the
stupidest clinical trial you could ever do because everybody
will receive 18 doses of anti-PD-1 and surgery, and
the only difference was they would give three doses of the anti-PD-1 before
surgery in a group of patients. So they said, "You're randomizing people to the
same treatment and the same treatment." I said, "No, no, no.
I think that the biology tells us something different." And it really did.
This is one of the most positive clinical trials I've seen coming out from SWOG.
The neoadjuvant therapy had an event-free survival that was markedly
improved, close to 50% improved than the patients who
received surgery and adjuvant therapy.
So with this, I
thought it would keep it light. I thought this is the end of the day on a long
meeting. So I just wanted to say that since I joined the faculty
of UCLA in 2001 with a dubious hairstyle,
there was
at most one in 20 chances for any patient with advanced melanoma to
respond to treatment. And currently, half of the patients
from any statistic that we have are living a
normal life. And this is because when they stood the science well,
we took it to patients with the development of targeted drugs.
And Neil Rosen, I shouted out
to you a couple of times. I'll show you the slides I went over before.
But understanding these mechanisms has allowed it to
improve things. And I look into the future, the science couldn't
be better. We have techniques now that allow us to do things that were
impossible to do before, study single cells and sequence
them and transcriptome in unprecedented ways.
I've been able to work on all of this and get recognition because it's been
group work with many of the current members of the lab,
Katie Campbell and Natalie. Where are you, Natalie?
I'm sorry.
Nasser Eldin should be here.
Past trainees, I've cited some of their work.
Junior faculty that
were recently trained in the lab and my colleagues and collaborators in many
places. My colleagues at SWOG, many of them being in the
audience, that have helped us translate these
scientific ideas into patients and practice-changing clinical
trials. And going back to
my lab members and the founders
of our lab.
So I'll be happy to take any comments or
questions.I
guess it's hard to make questions when I condense 25 years
into
20 minutes.
Maybe I'll start with a question, Toni.
Amazing talk and really amazing accomplishments.
And many patients, I think, are living longer because of all of
your efforts. So as you look to the future, I think, what are you particularly
excited about? What do you think the priority areas are
for melanoma, for example?
Yeah. Bless you.
Understanding the cancer better continues to be a focus
on developing therapies that block why it
behaves as a cancer. From the immune system part,
I
don't think that adding more
immune checkpoint blockade agents will get us there.
There's a certain number of cancers that are immunogenic, and melanomas,
and once you've released the main checkpoints,
there's no others. There's no other T cells that are stuck in other places.
So either they have to be activated with a vaccine approach,
or
we can
re-engineer the immune system to recognize the cancer.
And we're doing several studies where we're trying to develop new
CARs for surface proteins in cancer cells,
studying
alternative expressed proteins, and being able to make
these redirecting agents, which could be a CAR or now it
may be T-cell engagers or
in vivo gene editing.
Looks like there's a question. James?
Congratulations, Toni.
Thank you.
Very well-deserved award.
Very impactful work and great presentation.
So what can you tell us about the 30% of patients that
got neoadjuvant therapy and did not do as
well?
Yeah.
I don't think any immune checkpoint blockade will have 100% response
rate in any situation.
If we
bring the therapy earlier, we have better responses.
Some of the mechanisms of resistance are divergent evolution of the
cancer, where the
preexisting T-cells are
not able to control all of them. In the neoadjuvant setting, that's
brought earlier so then we can have better responses.
But there's a big drop at the beginning, and those are the
melanomas that are not immunogenic, I would assume.
That study included mucosal and cutaneous melanoma,
and that some of those cancers may have a lot less
immunogenicity with a lot less mutations.
And then if we push the system too much, then we can have the cancers
that escape the immune system, which is not that common at baseline,
because it hasn't had enough pressure with this loss of function
mutation in interferon signaling or antigen
presentation. But that's very rare.
Thank you.
Over here.
Thank you for the presentation. Congratulations on the award.
Thank you.
You've showed us that giving three doses of neoadjuvant immunotherapy
was actually very beneficial, and it resulted in 70% of pathological
complete response. When we did the other trial where you compared the
adjuvant versus the neoadjuvant, do you think there was a need for the adjuvant
in that trial? Because we're learning that the drug has a half-life that's long,
and it's present on the cell for a longer period.
So the question remains, do we really need the adjuvant if the
neoadjuvant is producing so many good results?
I think some of the data in
melanomas and other cancers that are responding to immunotherapy in the
neoadjuvant setting make us question if we're
over-treating. And I would not only think about the adjuvant therapy,
but what is the role of surgery? So if that patient
has an axillary mass and 20 lung metastases, and
you see the response in the axillary mass and the metastases, you don't go
and take it out. You don't take any of them out.
Not based on data, because I don't know why we
haven't been able to open a clinical trial where we test the
role of surgery in adjuvant
treatment in patients who are
responding to neoadjuvant therapy.
I would question the need for-
Yeah, it would be interesting to see adjuvant versus neoadjuvant only
to see if neoadjuvant is enough and we're not over-treating patients because
immunotherapy does have toxicities.
Agreed.
Okay. Well, that concludes this
lectureship, and let's congratulate Dr. Toni Ribas again.